we're good all right welcome everyone we'll uh call to order the uh committee of conference Thank you.
we're good all right welcome everyone we'll uh call to order the uh committee of conference on house bill 199 and we'll start with a quick introduction i'm howard perle chair of the environment agriculture i represent america district 26.
i am peter bixby ranking member on house environment and agriculture i represent strafford 17 and i live in dover i'm sue lamola i'm uh representative district 27 in polis and i'm a member of the environment agriculture center kevin avart district 12.
senator david waters jeff bradley wolf world representative judy aaron i'm Vice Chair of Environment and Agriculture and represent Sullivan District 7, which is at Worth, Goshen, Lincoln, Webster, and Washington.
Good morning.
All right.
So I know many of you have another committee you need to get.
Yes, we'll move the amendment.
All right.
We have moved and seconded.
So everybody, any questions on the amendment?
Not so much a question as a comment.
So I think that the biostimulant language being put in the soil conditioning statute does make sense.
I don't think, I think it would have been better to actually have a public hearing on this, because there are some questions in terms of what implications this has for regulation and things like, does compost count as a biostimulant?
If length of the biostimulant definition, then compost very well could be.
And then you get into how do you regulate that?
Are you going to require the same sort of, in terms of, are we going to be having parallel fee structures for biostimulants like we do for registering fertilizers.
A lot of questions like that that I would have liked to have been able to bring out in a public hearing.
But the underlying bill, the soil health bill, I think is more important.
And I'm not going to quibble about the process and there is a certain relationship between by plant bio stimulants and soil health um they are one of the one of the mechanisms or one of the tools you can use to encourage soil health so it's not completely out of the blue um and the soil health bill is really important for our conservation districts, because what it does is it puts soil health and resilience into the statute that is their guiding document.
and a lot of the funding that they get to do the actual work they do in terms of providing technical assistance mechanical assistance uh loaning equipment um etc comes through grant funding and these changes will put them in a much stronger position to apply for and receive grants so that's um my take thank you representative so senator bradley has moved uh amendment number two oh two one dash one nine two four h senator avar seconded it any other any further discussion i could just add i do has mitigation plans for living and i will just one of the one of the issues i had originally with this with adding some of this this without public hearing, I agree with you is that sometimes there's a lot of unintended consequences.
And sometimes when something gets added like this, it actually creates, as I was saying, an unintended consequence.
And it tends to be work for the people on the back end who are having to utilize this.
Thank you.
I would have liked to have had a public hearing on it because I think that adding something like this, first of all, to really understand biostimplates and understand if they apply a category of, say, fertilizer or how that is, is that a redundant statement?
Is it a just better defined type of fertilizer?
Things like that.
That would have actually been very useful.
And I know that Representative Vixby and I, we actually, this isn't sort of a defense thing, but we actually, he was kind enough to let me be involved in this at the later stages.
And we took quite a bit of time, but I did utilize the knowledge I have as an everyday has an innovation planner to make this something that was very useful and didn't go down a rabbit hole too much.
And I do just let you know, I do have some concerns about adding plant bio-stimulants.
I'm not really sure what rabbit holes I can create.
That's all.
Well, we had good discussion with the commissioner and he's willing to accept the changes we've made proposed in the amendment so are we all in agreement that the amendments will pass yeah let me just i just want to um sort of assuage some of the concerns there in terms of the the definition itself since we have put it in the definitions for um uh under the soil conditioner statute which is where it really belongs uh that's not going to create any the way we put it in there it doesn't create any obligations right and the way that we put the rulemaking authority in thank you howard uh is uh basically gives the commissioner a lot of control over uh what if any action needs to be taken on that definition so i've got to be sensitive to these so we're all in agreement that the amendment will pass yes and then these parts of the senate will agree to concur with the house amended bill so perfect thank you we should be good thank you very much thank you i understand thank you thank you Thank you.
Thank you.
I only do this because I got it for Christmas.
Reconvening of the committee conference for house bill 187 and as i think we all know we have no trouble with almost all of the bill but there is one sticky spot i'm first going to ask if any senator brought in language that could unstick us on the idea of oversight and review of commissioners.
I did not.
Okay.
Secondly, I actually have some language.
You have some language.
I'm sorry.
I am not hearing well here.
You said for oversight of the sticky spot that we have here on this bill.
I think I would have to talk to my colleagues before I introduce them.
Okay.
I would be interested in seeing the way we could go forward if you wish to have a...
Why don't we suspend five minutes five minutes yeah um and the other thing if i could add right now um the conference committee on 417 is meeting i'd like to think that by the end of the day today there'll be an agreement there my suggestion would be i mean i haven't seen what tom may have but once there's an agreement if there's an agreement on 417 that becomes very easy using saying standards that have been agreed upon on 417 to be applicable to 187 that would be would it make sense for us to meet again on the 16th no at 10.
do you prefer tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow's dead well why don't we why don't we at least take the five minutes let's take what he got because if if it's something that we want to go forward with or want to not go forward with if we can go back in that corner i'm sure that or we can do it okay so that's a lot of rooms here Thank you.
Thank you.
Understood.
Question.
If there's an agreement on 417, is it going to be the sense of you folks that we replicate the agreement?
Because if we come back at 9 o'clock on Thursday morning, we're up against the clock.
So we're going to have to, if there's an agreement on 417, we're going to have to draft it so that we have something to look at at 9 o'clock and go forth there.
I just can't make a representation until I see why.
I realize that, but I mean, is that a logical way to proceed?
It is.
Given the time pressure.
It will certainly be a good document to consider.
Did you folks have anything to bring back to us from your time out?
Just pretty much what Senator Bradley said is that the discussions that are going on in 4.17 right now look promising.
And if they continue the way they are, we're looking at replicating some of those words into this and going forward.
I have a few things before I see if anybody else does.
Number one is the thought occurred to me of a couple of police officers with whom I've had recent conversations, how they don't like the police civilian review board for the same reasons.
They're not cops.
They can't tell us what to do.
They don't know our job.
But yet many people, including many people to a certain end of the political spectrum, welcome civilian review boards.
And it's not exactly analogous, but it still is others making comments on professionals.
So I just thought I'd throw that out.
And secondly, Representative Acton has been working hard and has something to consider.
Throw this into the hopper, if you would, as a possibility.
All right, so we had some trouble with the photocopier here, but we got the copies out.
And this makes one small change to section eight.
So basically, so everyone has one.
So the change to section eight, realizing the gravity of reviewing and be sending an emergency order, we felt that it was a wise move to move to a two thirds majority requirement vote in order to create the joint resolution that would then move forward.
So that's, so the really, the only change here is moving from the simple majority to two thirds.
So we don't have that something that moves.
How many members are there on the oversight committee?
Presently, there are five.
If 187 passes, it will go to eight, with the House stipulating to some alternates.
But there would never be more than eight voting members.
Right, correct.
Five from the House and three from the Senate, which is exactly as the committee was constituted up until this year.
i mean the one thing i would say is that when one thing i guess for the fiscal committee some of the things they did a small group of 10 people speak for this is even bigger uh you know overriding the emergency like amended brought forward it's a very small i would have some position with that i think better off if there's an agreement 417 that's...
This suggests an amendment on its own, two-thirds of eight is five plus, so it would have to be six people.
And usually people on the oversight, at least several of them, have experience in the medical field or they've been on health and human services committee.
So it's not that we're picking senators and reps at random.
There is some knowledge.
I recognize that.
And we all love John Williams, too.
Wait a second.
Is that going to be a sticking spot on this?
It went over his head.
We all stipulated to love you, John.
Senator Sermon.
I can't hear you, sir.
I'm sorry.
This does not address the 90-day stay of action, which is really my sticking point.
It doesn't.
And that, to my non-legally trained mind, might leave this insufficiently vague, that the committee may vote to sponsor a resolution, ethics advisory committee weighs in, and so on.
There's no suspension pending a ruling.
Well, there is, because we didn't change that portion of the original stays.
if we're going out with the house having accepted three Senate members, we're still going to have a 90 day stay of action.
Okay.
Because this proposal did not take out Section 10.
Thank you, thank you.
Section 5.
I'd want to work on that because I would agree when medical things are in play 90 days is is not acceptable to me um with thank you mr chairman the with section 8 and section 10 being different sections would we not now want to just look at those individually if i know section 10 is a hang-up here, but could we potentially solve the issue with Section 8?
Since this only addresses Section 8?
You have an enabling, and then you have the prescription, if you will, but they're kind of two different things here.
If I may, Mr.
Chairman, we've already been told that one of the concerns, perhaps, there are two concerns concerns one of which is we're delegating to a very small number of people the power that usually resides in 424 and the second is what happens when they have done the resolution so we have changed the threshold for the resolution but the question, do we want to look at Section 10 on page 5, which gives the 90-day time frame, and do we want to perhaps have something drafted that has a shorter time frame for the stay?
because as it is now, if a joint resolution is introduced within either 20 business days of the vote or 20 business days of the start of the following session, and there is no stay until the resolution is introduced as I read this.
The commissioner shall be prevented from enforcing such an...
And then we probably ought to clarify that there is no stay until it's introduced because that's not entirely clear.
I mean, I'm just opposing my glass on the words.
No, that's good.
Then the commissioner shall be prevented from enforcing such emergency order, and perhaps we should say 30 days for action by the general court, whichever comes first.
I'm comfortable with 30 days.
I'm not comfortable with 90.
I'd like to...
I'm not comfortable with 30 days in the middle of a crisis.
I mean, we saw what happens in 30 days of inactivity in COVID.
Who knows what the crisis is.
So I think we need to wait until 417.
417.
I'm good with that.
Representative other Pearson, you said you had two questions, and you asked one.
Do you have a second one?
I probably did and genetics is a sick and powerful thing so I'll get to the stratosphere thank you everyone then we will we are recessed until 9 a.m.
Thursday in the same place it should be really young to be having that kind of oh see I have a until 9 a.m.
Thursday in the same place.
Thank you.
We have a forum.
Senator Prez.
Senator Gaida, Senator Prez.
All right.
Okay, reopening the Committee of Conference on House Bill 417.
Senator Gaida was tasked with producing an amendment based on our discussions yesterday.
He has such an amendment.
I see you too.
Bearing in mind this is the process.
All right, well, I'd like to start at the back to make sure, because I think we're all in agreement on Part 2, and I'd like to have everybody take a look at it and make sure that it says the important things that we're talking about.
No, Senator Carson's money.
You're talking about the money?
I think so.
Yes, Part 2 is not.
Maybe we'll discuss until Senator Carson gets here.
I'm not sure.
Well, we need to read and study it.
We need to read and study it.
Okay I'm not sure.
Okay.
For the viewers, we will be reading and studying for the next few minutes.
I hope Senator Carson will get here.
Time to do some of that also good afternoon senator yes as i said yesterday senator died always passed with an amendment uh here it is we are going to start with section two because i believe that if it that it may reflect our discussions and we may all be very happy with section two okay so take a look at it and uh see you know that's in there Thank you.
I think that's in there.
No, no, the section on the representatives of the people being able to travel.
I just want to make sure that that was in there.
It's on 9.5.
Yep.
Okay.
I don't think it's an item.
No.
I just typically.
It's very vague.
Well, an item is anything that is submitted.
I mean, it's general, but it's got it.
Obviously, it says it's an item for consideration.
It's relative to under this section, $100,000 and so forth.
I think the item is a term that we use when we're discussing this stuff on fiscal.
It's what they call a term of art.
So it doesn't mean he can just give them a pet rock.
You're dating yourself.
I am.
Once.
Only if it's more than $100,000.
Okay.
Yep.
Thank you.
any other comments or questions about park coot yeah okay no i think it's that's clarify i i went back and looked on page one clarify that uh consistent majority of members present and voting in each chamber acting separately.
Yep.
So I think that's about as explicit as you can get.
Yes.
We're on the finished page two.
No, I just wanted to make sure of reading the whole thing, because make sure that we're very, very clear.
Thank you.
Obrigado.
Procedural question.
So the legislature may terminate.
Both houses majority separately.
So let's say the House takes up a motion to terminate.
Is there anything compelling to send it or vice versa to take up the same motion?
Not in this language, no.
Although after it is voted in one chamber, it's normally sent to the other as a message.
I believe it's general.
Don't they have to accept the message?
Yes, we do.
I did the's general.
They have, don't they have to then accept the message?
Yes, we do.
And same thing with you folks, you have to accept the messages as well.
Right.
Because the Senate could very well do this and the House could say, no, we don't want to do this.
Without even taking the vote.
Whereas this, it allows for vote.
And I think it's important that it's a majority, and it's a simple majority.
It's not a two-thirds.
Right.
So that makes it much easier in the process in order to do that.
So there's not this high hurdle that you have to overcome.
Yeah.
Especially considering we'll be able to get projects about.
Right, if you don't know what the state of emergency is, whether the roads are going to be trying to travel on the roads or anything else.
Or if it's just one Senate district that's completely trashed in the rest of the states, OK?
Yeah.
So that would be .
So to answer my question, normal procedure would be that if the House took it up, we passed it, we would send a message to the Senate.
The Senate could choose to ignore the message.
They'd have to receive it, but they don't have to act on it.
But the normal procedure is that they would receive it and act on it yeah yeah yeah so it gives the each body the freedom to make a decision so and quite frankly if it got down this road i don't see just the House being upset at what's going on.
It would be the Senate would be, yeah, because we would be hearing from our constituents.
I was just trying to make sure we don't get lost in the weeds.
No, if it goes to this, it's not getting lost in the meetings.
Oh, that's good.
Okay.
While we were thinking about this last night, the House position is that the legislature needs to take an affirmative vote to continue a state of emergency at some point.
And Professor Blackus has some language that puts that into this bill.
We have some discussion about this earlier.
This isn't final language.
OLS is working on drafts of this right now.
But the idea is that 90 days, given 90 days from the declaration of state of emergency every 90 days thereafter, the governor shall convene and address a joint session and provide written copies of the address to all members of both chambers within five business days.
The legislature must affirm, shall affirm or discontinue the state of emergency by the majority vote of both chambers acting separately on the following question shall the current state of emergency continue and similar to the other language for the purpose of this section so the majority means i said the majority of members present voting chamber separately and you know there's going to be some os is going to strike out some language but that's the fact is there going to be an opportunity for the governor whoever the governor he or she might be to make their case to each body just right right at the beginning it okay so it shall convene an address to okay all right and then we can separate and provide a written copy of the address to all members okay so we actually see it okay okay i think it makes sense it gets everybody in the same room at the same time focused on the same issue this is what we've done this is what we need to do i you know it seems to make sense to me because it's not that and again this is the This is the first time we've been in such a situation it's also leisurely enough for the legislature that gives a governor three months which is a extraordinarily long emergency even a public health emergency after 90 days, you would expect a change.
And at that point, we can reconvene and say, is it still an emergency?
Should we continue?
But it doesn't interfere with the day-to-day management of the emergency or the short-term data.
It just says, you know, after 90 days, which would have been extended, we say, okay, should it be extended again?
Thank you.
The 90 days, which would have been extended, we say, okay, should it be extended again?
In here, we have 45 days.
Are we looking to amend that to 90?
No.
I think that the setting, this allows the governor one extension without our vote.
I don't think that's what the whole license takes.
Oh, well, well, but because most emergencies don't last longer than that.
Right.
So, okay.
So we're giving him 45 days and then he can do another 45 days.
And if he wants to go beyond that, we have to convene and talk about it but during the first and second extension we still have the authority to cancel it and cancel individual orders this is under section c right okay yeah this would add a section d that say where where after the initial emergency plus an extension, if the governor wants to extend it again, then we'd have to get together.
Which I think is 90 days is within the legislative time frame.
We're not supposed to.
No, we're not executive.
Well, I think that's why we're in this position.
Over a decade ago, we legislated for the motion and we may have created Frankenstein's monster and COVID-19 electrocuted it all night.
And now we're dealing so that we didn't know who could foresee this, you know.
Yeah.
And it was enough to convince us that there's issues with the current law and that we need to make a stab at fixing it.
So, thank you, Senator Beckett.
Emergency orders, so we'll be picking and choosing which ones we're going to keep or not keep?
No, we're going to pick and choose which ones to cancel.
Which ones to cancel.
Right.
Cancel.
May I take this one?
Yeah, please.
So based on what?
The motion of an individual representative or senator, a body, like what would that look like that would depend on the the rules of the body uh it could in the house it could be a committee that says you know e-dna looked at the governor's relaxation of licensing laws and said this is bad and so we would submit a resolution or an individual member could submit a resolution.
I'm not familiar with how the Senate works, but it's probably the same thing.
Yeah, Philip.
So what I'm hearing from you is that depending on our rules, there would be a hearing and an opportunity.
Somebody raised the issue.
This would come before the appropriate subcommittee a committee it depends it depends on the evanship we're just trying to feel it all the way i'm not sure i thought that through okay as to how we would actually rescind the number of orders so that's something we may want we may have to amend our own rules i think if the rules stand now I have to be be proud of the NCR.
And the normal person would answer it.
Unless the body votes to suspend the rules and take it up immediately if possible.
If they felt it was urgent, but the normal person would answer it.
I do have an affirmation from Senator Morse that the two-thirds requirement to bring in a resolution, for which we currently have some exemptions.
We move to incorporate this process as well, exempting the two-thirds requirements to bring in a resolution.
So the same applies here.
If after organization we invent rules, two thirds would be necessary.
So we would have to change our rules to exempt this particular statute.
There was discussion of doing that earlier.
Yeah.
It didn't have to move through.
But if we pass this law, we would have to amend our rules in a couple of places to make sure we weren't constructing it by rule and so i i don't even in mind this rules trump statutes house rules and senate rules at least but the uh statute trumps administrative rules yeah but not not the senate okay no i was thinking i want to take this a step further so there is this maybe a suspension there's a concern brought up once in the House or in the Senate, and then what I'm looking for is would there be a committee hearing that would be referred to the timing management appropriate committee.
I just want to make sure say, our experts, the people, the content experts that work with licensure, that work with emergencies in that particular area, have an opportunity to inform and interact with.
Senator, I think that would depend on whether or not we were in session at the time.
If we were in session, it could be you could do it.
If we're not in session, it's really hard to call a special session of a committee.
Thank you.
session at the time.
If we were in session, it could be you could do it.
If we're not in session, it's really hard to call a special session of a committee.
You might have a public hearing or whatever, but I would suspect.
But again, it depends on what the body chooses to consider appropriate.
We've often had cases where somebody brings in a bill and the argument is not on the content of the bill, but the fact that it didn't get a proper hearing.
I'm sure you've had that too.
So yeah, it's one of those debatable things.
I think what we would want to hear from is the governor's experts, to be frank.
If he issues a emergency order and one of the members to be the hey you know i i want to make a motion to kill that order first of all again we'd have to both parties would have to have a majority of both houses and they would give the governor's experts a chance to come in that's that's exactly my point whoever they may be yeah you're going to want to hear from the people who have the expertise in that area.
They may make that decision.
Exactly.
Thank you.
I totally agree.
But I also think it doesn't stop any one of us from reaching out to a governor and saying, hey, wait a minute, why did you do this?
Especially people who have a lot of subject knowledge.
Committee heads.
And just because we were not meeting virtually doesn't mean we didn't stay in contact.
And, you know, we had the task force that we were – Economic reopening task force.
Yes, and so we had all of that.
So as committees, we were, I think, pretty well aware of what was going on.
I know I was watching the emergency orders as they were coming through.
So if there was something that I can just speak from my own experience, if there was something that I was concerned about from an EDNA perspective of licensure or something, pick up the phone.
Hey, Carol, you know, she has my number.
I have her number, we talk to each other.
You know, what do you think about this?
And, you know, those kind of things happen.
We don't need legislation in order for something like that to happen.
I certainly agree with that.
In addition, if the legislature has the power to terminate individual orders, and it kind of becomes clear that some people in the House or the Senate or both have concerns about one of them, gives the governor some additional incentive to provide information and argument for it, both to committee chairs and to the whole box of homes, which I think is a good thing.
Some of that was missing at at times yeah i totally agree i think the biggest issue was we just didn't know i mean he has all these experts and he didn't really have the time or he didn't have to tell us why he was making these orders as things were coming up so if we have an issue now at least we get to say okay could you can we hear from what what's behind that i mean if it if a in order a resolution was brought up and there's some doubt it could certainly be referred to committee before i mean that's not a represent goalie you're scaring me down.
I'm just taking us all in right now and, you know, thinking about when things come up when we're not in session.
Not in session.
July to January.
January.
How would a member bring up a...
In that case, it's going to have to be more informal and relying on the initiative of each individual member.
We may have to add rules to the House and Senate.
There are rules under emergency.
There is already RSA 16 at least the House can petition for special session by if enough of them send a mail to the Secretary of State for a question.
So that's on.
Now I forget how the Senate i'm sure if they can just on the senate's we should shame on that i look at the house but i mean they're even i mean that's you don't even have to get together physically to at least in the request there's a provision at the very least if that turned out to slow, the governor calls a session in 90 days, the individual orders could be considered and debated there.
And was interesting the language.
and again this will be tweaked by all of us but 90 days from the date of declaration of the state of emergency and every 90 days thereafter, governors shall convene and address to joint session and provide written copy of the address to all members of both chambers.
I think the attendance within five business days, I think before we get together so we can look at it.
And the legislature shall affirm or discontinue the state of emergency by the simple majority of both chambers acting separately on the following question.
Shall the current state of emergency continue?
The governor would actually be required to make this case.
So that covers your concern about the paralysis, because he has to call this back.
that goes back covers your concern about if we're at a session because he has to call this back but back to your concern what if we're at a session and then a member wants to bring something forth I think we have to amend our early look at maybe 16 okay I just got a text, a fax from our...
something that's become applicable.
Representative Dwyer?
I just got a text, a fax from our note from Paul Smith saying the governor doesn't constitutionally have the authority to convene a joint session.
I presume that we will put in the appropriate word, call a joint session, I think is it?
Is it call?
Whatever the appropriate language, both chambers shall assemble and yes i could have sworn i've read somewhere where you can call us it may be the we're using the wrong word are we using the wrong word paul probably we'll use the right word yes senator he's watching yes he said so senator prentis you had two things crazy so as to when we're not in session i can think so being new um last december and january when we were not meeting, and in fact, in the Senate, we didn't have our first real session date until February, correct?
As there were many concerns that I received from constituents, and I just picked up the phone or emailed.
I mean, I addressed them as they came up.
I don't think there's anything that's ever precluded us from doing that.
And some of them related to orders, trying to understand why.
But I found the response from the state agencies of when I drilled down to the folks at the experts who were advising the governor and even the governor's office were very responsive.
So I guess I don't have so much of a worry about that but i do but something could come up so let me just kind of like i was thinking what's the role of the leadership for the speaker of the house and the president of the senate to be a conduit during the time of non-being in session to convene with i don't think convene is the right word but talk to the governor and then share you know message that message that out is that they are getting the notification of the spending okay we that's in part two that they're getting notification of the spending and they're the ones that would decide if from their standpoint they need to call a special session in order to deal with the in paragraph uh first page number nine as soon as practical the governor shall know without the speaker of the house and the senate president of impending issuance of emergency orders to me the heads up that it's coming yeah it's and our our i don't know about the senate but the house leadership is a very quality over time you know how much they communicate and how well but the senate is extraordinarily good all the time so you know you've got to deal with the people who've got that's all i can say it's just which is all good the wrong problem.
I'm sorry.
Just my experience, it's only my second term, but my experience being in the center, that leadership has been very good about, in general, about communicating.
I would expect in this kind of situation, would be .
But it's .
So then I guess this goes to you.
Why wouldn't it be just possible for the governor's office to notify the senate president and the speaker of the house of his statement to the full house and leave the speaker and the senate president to disseminate that information to its members i just think that's asking a lot of the office to track down the four hundred and twenty-four members when he tells each chamber has their list to the email i'm i'm sure that they can talk to each other are you talking about at the 98 point yeah i think when we meet that he says a copy of his correspondence to the host and senate shall be sent out within five business days to every member and why can't just speak to the senate president because of the house and the members giving information to each chamber on their own behalf because you have obviously our leadership has better insight onto the email addresses of entire members and make sure to be on their side and i think i would feel more comfortable with the 90-day period actually hearing from the experts and stylists than just, you know, a white paper.
I would trust any governor to get the information out as efficient as possible.
They could call on the House and say, here's my white paper consider power lines down or you know communications disruptions and things so my thought would be too i think in that joint address whatever it's a joint session or whatever you want to call it, that the experts will be there to take questions.
I mean, that to me makes the most sense.
Everybody's in the same room at the same time.
You can ask your questions.
Okay.
And then within five days, because I understand it, then the body, with that body's plural, will each individually express his opinion.
And the governor would provide his written arguments if that would necessarily take questions.
At at 2.
I'll be following you.
Yeah.
We i do as well so the other thing is they didn't they said sometimes it's accurate but they couldn't almost when the other issue is one of the things go down be the caller go down and straighten out a misunderstanding to make sure that it's 45 days i can do that unless unless you were just going to give it to you you've got to do it okay all right so that unless you were.
You've got to do it.
Okay.
All right.
So that means you're in it too.
Yeah.
So fine.
This is my last scheduled meeting.
Could you go on and do it and then they can send me a note if you can make something or how to do it.
I'll send you that.
Can we all reconvene again later?
I think it would be important to do that.
It depends on how long Senate Bill 155 is going.
I felt good about that.
Well, we have an amendment we're going to be looking at, but it's my understanding Representative Shewitt has been in contact with Lindsay Courtney.
Yes.
and they're going back and forth.
I, yeah, I know, I'm like, there's no, we have the amendment.
in contact with lindsay courtney yes and she they're going back and forth i yeah i know i'm like this no we we have the amendment and we're not going to add in for me okay right let's try and come back this afternoon when we say three i don't know if we recess um no i got an event at four um two two 3.
That gives us an hour.
Yeah.
Well, I'm hoping 3.55 is not going to take very long.
It's all right.
We could potentially be back here at 3.
Yeah.
3.15.
Just to recess?
Recess until 3.15.
Okay.
Or take a break until 3.15.
We're taking a break until 3.15 to wait to get the words from them.
Okay.
And I will go down and talk to LLS and make sure they will have something in writing.
Terrific.
All right.
Recess until 3.15.
Okay.
Thank you.
I need to check the room finally to make sure that they're available.
Hello again we're resuming.
I have in front of us amendment 1986 H which goes, which incorporates the changes that we wanted.
I think there was a miscommunication with the drafter.
And so online 17 and 18, where it says 90, that should be 30 days.
So that the governor...
90 days everywhere.
Right, it should be 30 there.
so that the initial declaration is for 30 days and the governor can renew it up to twice still gets money and then at the at the 90 if he wants a third renewal paragraph d which starts on page two kicks in and yeah so line 18 is also what is 30 is 30 17 and 18.
yeah and if i could say something um i know some people i think are uncomfortable some people are uncomfortable uncomfortable with 45 but in a sense it doesn't make any different it could be five days it's just the governor staff would have more work from issuing the thing and so some people talk about the meantime although i think it doesn't make a difference are a little more comfortable with 30 days but again on its own he can renew it to three times as opposed to once he can renew it two times to get three months as as opposed to once for the full time.
I don't see any material difference.
But 30 is closer to current loss.
Okay.
Yeah, actually we give it nine more days than current loss.
Okay, because the last version was 45 days.
Right.
So now we're back down to 30.
Yeah.
But we've changed it.
It was 45, and then we had to affirmatively act, I believe.
Now it's 90, and we have to affirmatively act, but it's 30 days.
The question is whether or not.
If you strongly prefer 45, we're okay, but I think 30 is more appropriate.
I mean, ones that brought up the 45 days, not the Senate.
All right.
And then back on page two, there's a new section D, which says that 90 days, the governor shall call constitutional citation, part two, article 50, and address a joint session.
Thank you.
constitutional site citation part two article 50 and address a joint session and at that joint session the legislature shall either affirm the renewal or terminate the state of emergency both chambers would vote a majority on the positive continuation.
Simple majority.
All right.
Yes, sir.
What happened with the...
Some bodies affirming the executive orders.
That's still in section and paragraph C on page 1.
Good point.
Where is that there?
That's the state of emergency.
That's around 1.
It's got to be, oh, that is incorrect.
That is seriously incorrect.
Good catch.
Thank you, Jeff.
I am embarrassed to say I didn't notice that.
And also, does it still say present motion?
Yeah, it does.
Yes?
Read the sinker.
or any emergency order that is important i want to make sure it wasn't this one no no you're you're absolutely correct and i'm glad you all right So basically the changes we're talking about are the 90 to 30 and 1, 17, 18, and adding in the EO and 1, 21, so.
That's correct.
Definitely need to do that.
So who changed renew to request to renew a in 26?
I, that was, that was Jeff.
I, I, I, I think it should be that, um, no, I mean, really it, it, the, it's not a matter of the governor's power.
It's the state of emergency shall terminate upon the adoption.
Right?
Because he doesn't have to request before that, so it doesn't make any sense.
Right.
The state of emergency shall terminate, and I think that's the...
So everything from the initial D to state of emergency goes.
Yes, I think so.
It's a state emergency shall terminate upon the adoption of a concurrent resolution under the subterranean.
There's no request.
What are we striking?
We're on line 26.
On 25, we're adding the specific emergency order after state of emergency.
They determine the state of emergency.
Or any emergency order issued there under.
26 and 27, the governor's power to request renewal of the declaration all goes away.
It's just a state emergency shelter.
Yeah.
That makes a lot more sense.
So striking again, 26 26 everything up to the second sentence just start the sentence with a state of emergency i apologize for screwing that up thank you jeff it's been a long day.
It's been a long two days.
We're trying to push it off.
All right.
What I would like to do is have a vote that we would accept the amendment with those changes and have everybody read them before they sign off, which won't be until tomorrow, I'm sure because of the...
We're not prepared to vote yet.
Okay.
We're not prepared to vote.
Fine.
I will...
In that case, no sense of us taking it up.
Okay.
I will get this amendment fixed and we will...
Will you be ready tomorrow morning?
Yes.
Thank you.
amendment fixed and we will uh have will you be ready tomorrow morning yes okay i i i'm probably the person who has the biggest issue because i'm going to be in committee conferences from eight o'clock until noon i have one i have one at eight thirty i'm available anytime Thank you.
I have one at 830.
I'm available anytime.
As long as I get out the time for my haircut.
Can we do noon?
No.
Okay.
I think that makes sense.
I will request everyone.
Okay.
So we're going to recess it until now and we'll get and this this will be these these errors will be fixed with my sincere apologies no it happens it's okay okay terrific blame remember the 90th i'm grossly embarrassed about the no it's look we're all kind of running around and they are working and yeah just be glad this didn't come before the budget that they were working on the budget yeah well they're probably what they want to work so yeah okay all right so we will see tomorrow at noon for the final time i hope i i certainly have so at least on this i will be okay i don't know if we will be in the room but we are assigned all right well we'll watch for that notice carol thank you very much all right All your efforts.
Thank you.